amazon's plans for stargate start to
emerge
but there's one massive rumor knocking
around the mgm offices that will really
excite stargate fans welcome to
sidetrack your sci-fi tv and movie
channel
[Music]
as you might know july this year is
going to mark the 25th anniversary of
stargate what you also might know if you
currently subscribe to amazon prime
particularly here in the uk is that
stargate isn't actually on prime you
can't actually watch it for free you
have to buy the episode by the box sets
you can watch sgu but that's on the mgm
side product you have to pay 5.99 i
think a month for that
now please get in the comments if you're
from the united states or elsewhere
around the world can you currently watch
stargate on prime i suspect not
but that is going to change
because there is a big rumor knocking
around the mgm offices and if you are
regular sidetrack you'll know that i
have contact with a couple of people
that work in and around mgm now i have
to say straight away this is not fact
this is a rumor this is something that
is knocking around the offices that
they've been talking about
it's not confirmed
but
the rumor is that for the 25th
anniversary july this year amazon plan
to release stargate sg1 back onto amazon
prime amazon prime proper so we'll all
be able to watch it within our original
package
there's going to be more
amazon love to really build up hype on
these things i've been talking about how
the plan
all along really if the sale went
through quickly was to create a movie
followed by a series a movie to really
build up a lot of hype followed by a
series and then maybe a couple of other
movies couple of other series spin-offs
and so on and so on if it's popular
amazon are looking at disney plus and
the way they're running that streaming
service and they look at things like
marvel and the way they do it and they
think that stargate could mirror that
sort of model for how to produce the
television series not the style but the
way it's actually released
that is the plan seemingly going
forwards at the moment the thinking
still is particularly now the sale has
gone through so quickly even quicker
than they were expecting
for a movie to be announced and when
would be the ideal opportunity for that
movie to get announced
around the 25th anniversary
but more than that
putting sg-1 onto amazon prime will be
another way to build a little bit of
hype
and they'll almost certainly be a
documentary or something else produced
but you know that's just me thinking on
top of my head
mgm have an opportunity now to really
begin hyping towards this movie and the
main reason why it'll be probably a
movie before the television series is
that's what worked before and it's what
will work again stargate is actually the
10th highest grossing mgm movie of all
time and amazon would love to recreate
that
actually it was a massive surprise hit
the guys that produced um the first
target series thought it was going to be
a massive flop they tried to sell it to
larger studios and nobody would buy it
mgm ended up buying it for five million
dollars if there is anything that amazon
though are very good at doing it's
marketing a product this seems to be the
rumor of the guy i spoke to who firmly
believes this is the way amazon will go
he hears his little whispers and he's
putting two and two together here he
might be getting two and two together
and making six but hopefully he's on the
right track and to be honest i
completely believe where he's going with
this because it makes sense
there are big meetings planned for the
4th of april onwards between amazon and
mgm executives
and the executives in charge of
marketing on both sides are in
attendance to those meetings that is not
a coincidence that is because it's not
just about making a good product it's
about selling a good product and that's
what amazon are really really good at
so
we're going to see what happens these
meetings that begin the 4th of april i
think we'll start seeing a lot of these
ideas flashing out
but then
around july i thoroughly expect for one
sg-1 to reappear on amazon prime and
then two a big announcement around
stargate around the same time
so
suddenly the clock is ticking the sale
has gone through the ink is dry it's
time for less rumors less thinking and
knocking ideas around the mgm office and
actually start making some decisions
some official news hopefully will follow
really really quickly but
fingers crossed i'll get it to you first
so
please like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out
thumbs up on the video not thumbs down
and you're also welcome to share the
video wherever the hell you like
also you can become a fully fledged
sidetracker and consider hitting the
join button it really helps the channel
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you really soon
you